it's getting good Senate Judiciary
Committee members are pressing Susan
Rice to explain by next week
a newly revealed the email she's sending
herself an email talking about her
conversation on January the 5th with the
president reassuring herself and I guess
the president that this would be done by
the book
I think that's odd and disturbing
because we know that the investigation
regarding the Trump campaign was
anything but by-the-book and the email
also indicates the Obama administration
may have withheld information on the
Russia probe from the Trump team
meanwhile there's new information on
Michael Flynn's guilty plea who better
to explain it all than former federal
prosecutor Andy McCarthy who joins us
from New York all right Andy I've been
dying to talk to you but let's first hit
Susan Rice because it seems like she's
back I mean she was there to save him on
Benghazi went out and lied about the the
deal with what caused the attack in
Benghazi and now she's back again with
what certainly looks like a CY a email
to herself yeah the question is which a
was she seeing it appears and you know
there's two interesting things about it
one is this by-the-book stuff which you
would think at the very tail end of the
administration that always did it by the
book it wouldn't be necessary to tell
people that things needed to be done by
the book particularly when is Senator
Graham points out the this thing was
anything but done by the book unless the
book is like rules for radicals right I
guess they didn't identify the book but
the the other interesting thing that you
that you point to is this holding out
that they're laying the groundwork to
hold out information so President Obama
wants to know over the next couple of
weeks if there's any reason why we can't
share with the incoming team and you
know what you have to think about what
was going on then they were
investigating Flynn at that time and he
is going to be Susan Rice's successor
who you would think she would be
cooperating with and would be sharing
information with and yet they were
regarding him as a criminal
fact they were thinking about doing a
Logan Act prosecution on him which is
absurd they ultimately had the FBI go
speak to him and and ended up
prosecuting him for false statements so
I wonder if they're laying the
groundwork to not let him in on things
because they're regarding him as a
suspect rather than her successor and
you know a friend of mine today reminded
me of when we were in the Reagan
administration and he was in there in
the last few days that you're usually in
the last few days you're not you're not
still sending emails and I don't know
what time that email dropped I don't
know if it was was it before 12:00 noon
when I was what timing
they say that they say 12:15 Laura which
is when she should have been clearing
out her office right and if she says no
no 12:00 12:15 she is gone
this is Trump land after 12 o'clock
right right but she's still she's still
using government email and and I think
she still had her security clearance but
I think she's creating a government
document on purpose and we know that's
not always the usual thing in the Obama
administration often they tried to not
create government documents when they
were doing government work but they she
clearly was making a paper trail here
and he also what ask you quickly about
this this deal with Robert Porter and
this whole thing with this you know
ex-wives and accused of abuse and the
time line that looks like it might be
different from what the administration
initially said given what the FBI
director said today what's going on with
these security clearances and
individuals who are still working in the
White House without security clearances
is that normal
yeah it's not normal for people to be
working for an extended period of time
at the White House without a full
permanent security clearance and it
looks like what happened here that looks
like the nub of the problem right now is
the White House evidently said that the
FBI investigation was continuing as of
recently and in fact it looks like
according to what director ray says they
had wrapped that up last year oh my
goodness well and Ebola will keep on
this with you great insights as always